en pixar construimos nuestras películas
toma x toma una toma es algo que hacemos
al realizar montajes de nuestros
personajes en un escenario y luego
enmarcar a estos personajes a través de
una cámara cada vez que el punto de
vista de la cámara cambia
esa es una nueva toma en promedio una
película de pixar está compuesta de 1800
tomas eso quiere decir que hay una nueva
toma casi cada tres segundos en la
animación no se trata simplemente de
lanzarse a crear tomas primero tenemos
que determinar la historia y esto lo
hacemos creando un ánima tico este es
una versión rápida y esquemática de la
película hecho de decenas de miles de
dibujos el ánima tico hace más que
simplemente contar la historia alude a
un montón de cosas como la composición
el movimiento de la cámara la actuación
y la ubicación el ánima tico nos da un
buen lugar para empezar a pensar en cómo
vamos a hacer estas tomas en la realidad
realidad en el sentido del mundo virtual
tridimensional de la computación gráfica
esta lección te mostrará cómo las
transformaciones geométricas que son
funciones básicas para controlar la
orientación la posición y el tamaño de
un objeto
una parte esencial de la construcción de
nuestras tomas estás listo puesto yo
trabajo en el departamento de escenarios
como decorador virtual a menudo el
escenario empieza simplemente como una
habitación vacía
usando el anima tico y el material de
referencia del departamento de arte
averiguó que objetos necesitamos incluir
inicialmente en el escenario en esta
etapa antes de que las cámaras comiencen
su labor no se trata de hacer que el
escenario luzca bonito así que sólo
incluyó cosas que sean esenciales para
el montaje de la toma selecciono los
modelos virtuales que necesito los nuevo
a su lugar en la habitación volteándolos
y modificando su tamaño si es necesario
cada uno de estos cambios en el modelo
se realiza mediante transformaciones
geométricas cuando termino con esta
primera pasada la envío a montajes del
departamento cámara el montaje es donde
averiguamos cómo filmar la película a
través del lente de una cama
virtual así que echemos un vistazo a la
toma que vamos a realizar
en la cinematografía el movimiento de la
cámara es una herramienta poderosa para
transmitir emociones en la audiencia de
manera subconsciente es decir la cámara
es de mano o está sobre una plataforma
rodante o una grúa
acaso el personaje está experimentando
algún momento importante sobre el cual
estemos haciendo énfasis para esta toma
seguiremos la acción con nuestra cámara
haciendo un paneo con boening conforme
se mueve a través del espacio
a veces
cuando acabamos de configurar la cámara
la toma regresa escenografía ahora que
sé cómo se ve el escenario a través de
la cámara puedo realizar una versión más
detallada agregaré objetos para que el
escenario se sienta más creíble a veces
esto significa agregar muchas cosas en
montones desordenados para darle la
sensación de la habitación de un
adolescente o llenar las cajas de un
estante para que parezca una guardería
infantil pero se sienta como una prisión
y todas esas matemáticas bien usamos
transformaciones geométricas en cada
paso de la construcción de la toma en
esta lección tendrás la oportunidad de
usar transformaciones geométricas y
explorar conceptos tan simples como la
adicción y tan picantes como la
trigonometría para construir tu propia
toma